in the last video we talked about the
meaning of current and current is
defined to be the movement of charge
amount of charge per second we looked at
a copper wire where electrons are
carrying the current and we looked also
at a salt solution where both positive
and negative ions are carrying the
current across this imaginary boundary
where we we keep track of how many
charges are moving so now next we need
to talk about how do we define a
positive current what is a positive
current mean so I'm going to move this
up a little bit and we're going to get
to something that causes some confusion
but we'll try to clear it up here the
positive sign this is a convention that
we use the positive sign for current is
the direction that positive charges move
so that's the direction this is the
direction a positive sodium ion moves
this is the direction a negative
chlorine item moves when I assign a
positive direction to the current the
overall positive direction is going to
be in this direction that's plus current
plus current
all right and the same thing actually
holds for a wire if I draw let's go back
and draw my wire again if I draw my if I
draw my copper wire and inside there we
know that all these little electrons all
the electrons are moving in that
direction
so Q minus is moving in that direction
and when I assign a direction for the
arrow for a current the current arrow
points this way plus current so for
instance if I had 10 electrons per
second that we're moving in this
direction here I would say the current
is plus 10 charges per second in this
direction and you ask yourself if if
it's always electrons carry current why
why on earth do we point the arrow in
the other way and that actually goes
back way back in history to our friend
Ben Franklin Bren Franklin is the person
who said who basically made a decision
that said the charge on an electron is
minus now when he made that decision
nobody knew there was such a thing as an
electron so Ben Franklin
oops I n and that was in the year 17:47
Ben Franklin is a person who assigned
plus and minus as being the two types of
charge that existed and when he did that
he had no idea nobody had any idea that
there was such a thing as an electron
electron was discovered by a physicist
named JJ Thompson in the year 1897 that
was when the electron was discovered and
believe it or not if we do the
subtraction here look at this it's 150
years for 150 years of electric research
we were able to figure out a lot of
really good things assigning current
going in the opposite direction of
electrons in metal and it's all okay
it's all okay one of the questions is
often asked by new students is well why
don't we switch it around so the current
points this way why don't we why don't
we assign an electron why don't we make
current go this way
so why didn't we just switch it around
well we had 150 years of experience and
now we've actually had another 120 since
the discovery of the electron and we've
managed to get by with this we have not
chosen to do it one of the reasons we
don't do it is because it would
basically it would be a big mess
imagine if for instance in say in the
United States we decided oh driving on
the right side of the street is the
wrong side of the street we want to all
drive on the left imagine the chaos that
would cause now before we made the
change
everybody managed to get where we're
going and after the change everybody
would get there going but the changeover
would be just so so costly and the same
thing in with electricity we can do
perfectly well talking about current
going the direction of a positive charge
just like we did here with the positive
sodium going in an electric going in in
this direction this is actually how
electricity is conducted in your body so
it's not uncommon to have positive
charge moving around that's that's the
definition of current in a nutshell we
put a boundary across and you watch the
charges going through in either
direction whichever direction they do
and you count up and you get Q per
second that's current